my name is caitlin golcini and i'm the
academy anchor on the red carpet of
thing too
[Music]
tori kelly oh my god i'm such a big fan
of her hi it's so good to meet you
too caitlyn you look amazing you are the
first celebrity i met
i am oh my goodness who's your favorite
character
my favorite character is ash and you
thank you hey
wow
that's your enemies
oh with the academy hello you're
shivering yeah they got to get you a
space eater or something campbell soup
you are my favorite character in the
movie oh yay yes that's awesome
oh my goodness what's your name my name
is kenny
and i think you're a star oh thank you i
can't wait to meet you legend
[Applause]
when i was your age
i was like the biggest fan of his band
u2 and so it was like my
dream come true so if it could happen to
me it could happen to you who would you
want me
i would want to sing with you no way
i got you an early christmas gift can i
open it now yeah
i think you earn a
did you get me an oscar
proud mum should i just walk up down
i think he likes it i just want to say
you're amazing and hilarious at changing
your voice thank you so much
is that good
yeah
do adults
um love animated movies just as kids do
i think so you know adults animation's
been around for 100 years so adults grew
up on animation and adults are always
looking some for something to
do with their kids and also distract
their kids because they're very tired
their kids
are killing them
slowly it's a slow death but they're the
kids are designed to replace the adults
and they're just tearing them down so
you know
when you have kids you're just so
exhausted anything that gets your kids
attention you're like thank god
yeah somebody think about it's a lot
it's heavy nice meeting you yeah thanks
i think that's where we should end it
that's a wrap back to you academy
[Music]
you